mais d'abord vous le savez peut-être
plusieurs changements entrent en vigueur
le 1er janvier hausse du salaire minimum
et des gratifications des stages permis
de conduire à 17 ans ou encore le tri
des biodéchets il est parfois difficile
de se retrouver plus de détails avec
lesat
Turquie 2024 une nouvelle année qui
apporte son lot de nouveauté à commencé
par les revalorisations désormais le
SMIC s'élèvera à 1766 € brut par mois
soit une augmentation d'1,3 % même chose
pour les retraites avec une hausse de
5,3 % une autre augmentation qui elle ne
fait pas l'unanimité c'est celle du prix
du paquet de cigarettes jusqu'à 1 € de
plus selon les marques avec donc des
prix qui dépassent parfois les 12 € le
paquet en soit c'est une bonne idée
c'est un site à moins fumer donc voilà
mais moi ça me gêne un peu donc on garde
l'argent pour le réinvestir dans dans la
nourriture quoi moi je suis une fumeuse
j'ai arrêté 10 ans et voilà on reprend
on est quand même c'est très très
difficile je sais pas si la hausse va
tant impacter que ça l'arrêt du tabac et
ça fait charpayé mais bon du coup c'est
des bonnes raisons d'arrêter de fumer un
prix qui monte et des ventes qui
baissent côté buraliste ici en 20 ans le
nombre de paquets vendus a été divisé
par deux malheureusement ben un couloir
d'achoix va être un petit peu compliqué
je pense ça va
favoriser activement la contrebande qui
est déjà très active sur tour toute
autre nouveauté pour 2024 le permis de
conduire accessible désormais dès l'âge
de 17 ans plus besoin d'attendre donc la
majorité pour passer l'examen sur les
routes toujours on note aussi la fin du
retrait de points pour les petits excès
de vitesse l'amande elle est conservée
changement également pour ma prime renve
le mode de calcul de l'AED évolue à cela
s'ajoute la possibilité de se faire
accompagner lors de ces rénovations
énergétiques enfin l'obligation de trier
ses biodéchets et plus chur coquille
d'œuf ou branchage tout doit être
composté les collectivités locales sont
tenus de mettre à disposition un système
permettant leur collecte pour tous les
citoyens toutes les nouvelles mesures
appliquées depuis le 1er janvier 2024
sont à retrouver sur le site du
gouvernement
economie.gouov.fr